and the current president and first lady
spent about 20 minutes with the bushes
at the Blair House that's the
presidential guest quarters near the
White House where I'm told the entire
Bush family has packed in even with some
air mattresses on the ground in the
Blair House I'm in a while inside
information I guess their major Garrett
is here major good morning good morning
so the clash between President Trump and
the Bush family we've all noticed it's
disappeared entirely since the former
president's death president Trump's
presence today at mr. Bush's funeral
reinforce a thaw that began last summer
when the Bush family let it be known to
the White House that the first family
would in fact be welcome when the time
came for a funeral for the 41st
president and really in so many ways it
couldn't be and would not be any other
way the Bush family prizes the
presidency its resiliency and its bond
among the presidents preventing
President Trump from attending the bush
funeral would have undercut those goals
and made at least part of the story
about an excluded mr. Trump today the
focus by design will remain on the
presidency life and legacy of mr. Bush
with all living presidents paying
tribute and the scene of unity is likely
to spare president Trump's some of the
harshness visited upon him at Senator
John McCain's funeral on edge that
somewhat surprised this White House and
it's worth noting it's been first lady
Melania Trump who has privately noted
the bush family's outreach and respect
when conversations about this day of
commemoration first began it's nice to
see that yeah it's right it shows again
major the class that this family has and
and their respect and honor for the
office of the presidency and president
Trump moving into this club of
presidents and seeing the institution as
a bigger more permanent aspect of
American life than even he is and he's a
strong personality he loves that sense
of himself but the presidency even at
times like this or maybe especially at
times like this reminds you of its
strengths and its reach and it's a very
small Club I hope people make note of
that today